the last election the figures are stark
there was a sort of crossover between
our support and and age and frankly what
we didn't have at the last election was
so I think what we did have in 2015
which was that everybody was able to say
this is something the Conservative Party
wants to do for me if I'm older they
want to help me with this if I'm younger
or a student or a working mom or a new
business person you know we didn't have
that retail offer that people were able
to point to and say this is why I'm
gonna vote conservative let's develop
this critical voice of yours within the
conservative party and focus in even
more depth than that's speaking to
students at Loughborough college this
morning their view appeared to be that
you know not just that the Conservatives
weren't giving them something to aspire
to they weren't listening to the
concerns of younger voters in to what
extent do you think that's true well
because as a local MP I do a lot of
engagement obviously with college
students with university students and
with many others but of course one MP
listening and I can see what they're
saying which is that you know the
politics at the moment particular I
think given the result of the referendum
last year where many young people did
not support the direction of travel so
they are very frustrated you know if we
aren't listening then that's clear we've
got to do a lot lot better yeah you've
got Jeremy Corbyn talking about tuition
fees you've got Jeremy Corbyn talking
about home building and where is the
offer from the Conservatives at the
moment to the demographic which you need
if you're going to survive as a
political party we see I think that
actually one things the Conservatives
need to do much more is to explain
obviously the Conservative Party one of
our strongest elements for reputation is
how we manage the economy and I was a
Treasury Minister right back when George
Osborne and others are engaged in
turning the economy around and we kind
of make assumptions that when we talk
about a strong economy we talk about
jobs everything else young people are
going to know and others are going to
know exactly what we mean is in it for
them I think actually as a party we've
got to go much more back to first
principles explaining why they call you
matters wife you don't have people
paying their taxes you can't afford the
public services that people want why we
want to create jobs who creates jobs
that they don't just come out of thin
air and of course you're right housing
is a big issue both building more how
for people to buy but also houses for
people to rent and we haven't really as
a party talked much about rented
accommodation who's responsible for this
I mean I think I'm going to suggest one
name to reason me well look the party
actually in terms of a policy formation
is you know lots of people are involved
in all of that yes just a shorter the
ultimate responsibility though whoever
is the leader has to shoulder the
responsibility for the way the party is
conducting itself the policies that are
put forward in a general election and I
don't think any conservative can
possibly say that the 2017 general
election delivered the result that we
wanted nor that the manifesto landed in
the way that obviously it was hoped that
it was it was going to so look mistakes
made I think lessons are being learned
in our conference there's going to be a
huge amount of soul-searching on the
campaign we don't those lessons being
done particularly on the part of the
prime minister speaking again to your
constituents today even those who are of
the opinion that brexit was the right
choice fuel that she is disconnect he'd
feel that the general election removed a
lot of the respect that they had for him
well I mean I can't pretend otherwise in
the sense that the general election that
the focus was put very much on you know
Theresa May as the leader of the
Conservative Party and despite the fact
that we got more votes you know we
didn't get the number of seats we wanted
to have a majority so that clearly was
not a successful campaign strategy I
think everybody recognizes that the
question is going to be actually what do
we do going forward you know I think I'm
saying to somebody the other day that
we've got to be a team now in in
government it's about the cabinet being
a team I think people don't just want to
see one person they want to see the team
what's the team doing in terms of
developing policies that speak to me as
a voter
well it's let's talk about brexit are we
getting it right at the negotiating
table well clearly she's awfully deep in
take a breath I mean the answers got to
be we're not there yet we haven't got a
negotiated settlement I think there are
elements and I've been quite open about
this there are things that have been
taken off the table single market and
customs union were taken off the table
very early and we
now in a position of of arguing and
about whether a fact they should be put
back on the table or put back in some
form you know I do welcome the fact that
over the summer the position papers
imply that a transition period is on the
cards but I really hope that the Prime
Minister will be explicit about that
when she talks and it gives this speech
next week what's your view then your
personal view on the the New Deal brexit
is no deal truly better than a bad deal
look I don't agree with that
I think that I very much hope that the
no deal scenario is does not come true I
think it would be really very very
difficult for our economy to survive
that without it no there'll be a huge
impact on our economy if we'd have no
deal if we would have a sort of cliff
edge and those who say that it wouldn't
be a problem on not listening to the
voices of those who are exporters who
are employers public services to rely
when people come to the EU to work here
and others and also just add EU citizens
they are really really worried about
their status I don't think they need to
be I think we could do more to clarify
that but I don't want to see people who
have come here as taxpayers as employees
who are giving a lot to this country to
be worried about their status so I think
for all those reasons you know again I
hope that the Prime Minister will make
very clear that and she has privately
and she has publicly she wants there to
be a deal and I think she's absolutely
right well let's finish by talking about
Tories me as you mentioned you are now
on the back then she's a position of
great significance in terms of the
Treasury select committee of course but
you are rather more able to speak your
mind so who should replace to easily
into speculation because actually I
think okay so who shouldn't replace too
easily that's an easier way well I think
I'm not a now I'm going to get into it
today so I don't get I do think it's
helpful because actually I don't think
it's a debate we're going to be having
for you know several more years but the
point goes back to I represent a
Midlands marginal seat I represent the
kind of seat that conservatives need to
hold if we're going to have a majority
in government and I think that a
Conservative government is the best
thing for this country so whoever we
have as leader has got to appeal to
people in seats like mine and in the
seats that we lost this year and the
seats that we didn't
wind doesn't strike me the Jacob we
smoke we go down particularly well on
marketplace Jake who's very welcome to
visit Laura market I'm sure you would
like the antiques market in particular
and let's see maybe that's right they're
coming to a beauty parade in Laura to
see who's going to be the next leader